I'M OKAY WITH THAT.
WELL WE WERE ONE SHORT OF A
QUORUM IN THIS IN HIS --
COMMITTEE MEMBER NUMBER.
SEVEN ARRIVES WILL.
GET UNDERWAY IN ALL BE TURN IN
THE GAVEL OVER TO MR MAYES.
AND I'LL PRESENT MY HUMBLE
[inaudible]
BILL [inaudible]
HUMBLY.
ALL I ALL EYES ARE ON THE DOOR
MISTER COOPER IS IN THE HOUSE.
YOU JUST GAVE US A QUORUM
[inaudible]
BROTHER JIM.
CALL THE HEARING TO ORDER.
TAKE ROLE IN ESTABLISHING QUORUM
[inaudible]
HERE [inaudible]
HERE
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
TODAY.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE MISTER
DALY [inaudible] FOR YEARS.
THANK YOU INITIALLY CHAIR.
THIS BILL SIMPLY CLARIFIED THAT
GROUP LIFE INSURANCE POLICIES
MAKE COVER FORMER EMPLOYEES AND
RETIREES.
HAS BEEN SOME QUESTION ABOUT
THAT IN THIS CLARIFIES THAT
THOSE POLICIES MAY INDEED COVER
FORMER EMPLOYEES AND RETIREES.
WITH BOTH SECOND.
THANK YOU WITH ME AS THE BILL'S
SPONSOR.
CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN SHRINK
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LIFE AND
HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
CONSIDER ANY BETTER OURSELVES
SEQUESTER AYE VOTE.
GREAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND IS THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR VICE CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS ROBERT RELATIVE PART
OF INSURANCE WE HAVE NO OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WERE
ABLE.
TO A WORK THINGS OUT WITH A
CLICK ON THIS PROVISION AND
RECOMMEND CONCURRENCE THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SING NOW COME BACK AFTER ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MEMBERS.
SEEN ON THE MOTION IS MADE BY
HILL WAS THAT --
MISS I WHO MISTER COOLEY.
IF I SECOND MISTER FRAZIER --
THERE'S NOTHING FURTHER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY THREE WITH
RECOMMENDATION THE SENATE
AMENDMENT BE CONCURRED IN.
DAILY OUR DAILY AYE MAYES AYE
AYE MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CABALLERO
[inaudible]
CALDERON.
CHEN AYE CHEN AYE CHIU.
COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE COOPER --
COOPER I HAVE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER AYE AYE
[inaudible]
HARPER I NINE ZERO THAT DATA.
NINE TWO ZERO I'M ALL LEAVE --
THEY HEARING OPEN --
FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON OTHERWISE
THAT CONCLUDES THE OUR BUSINESS
IN TERMS OF MANY VOTES WE NEED
TO CAST THANK YOU ALL.
IS THAT FAIR
WE ARE ADDING ON NO
MISTER CHIU --
CHIU AYE.
IT WAS JUST ONE BILL
[inaudible]
HE DID.
EVEN SHORTER THAN WHAT I SO
OFTEN